I'm sure you're raring to get to work on
the conference central application
you've already downloaded the code from
github let's take a look at the layout
of the folders in the downloaded code so
here's where I downloaded the code you
see there's a folder for each lesson
less than two less than three and so on
inside each folder you see folders
containing the code to import into
eclipse
you already imported this one the hello
endpoints project and the next we're
going to be importing the first of the
central conference central projects
which is this one here some folders like
Lesson four include partial code these
folders contain classes or fragments of
code that you'll be adding to your
project in that lesson for the
conference central application we
provide starting code for each lesson
you can start working on it was a
starting code in the lesson2 folder and
keep working on it throughout the course
at any point if you need you can import
the starting project for that lesson you
might want to do that for example if you
didn't finish all the coding exercises
in the previous lesson so now it's time
to import the conference central project
from the lesson2 folder into eclipse
and down here in the Advanced section if
you want you can enter a name for your
project
every maven project has an artifact
which is used as its name but you didn't
create the artifact for this project so
feel free to add your own name if you
want so see up here I have my conference
central project and the Java code is
inside the SRC folder inside Chrome
Google devrel training conference and
you'll see the different packages in the
conference package so go ahead and
import the project into eclipse and then
answer a couple of questions the two
files you're going to be working with in
this lesson a profile Java room
conference API Java when you figured out
what packages therein come into the
values here
where is profile dot Java and which
package is conference API dot Java in